La volta amb una peu
Dia 214
Com costa
acampar
en aquesta zona del país
Com és una vall
les zones planes estan reservades
a les cases
I bueno, he trobat aquest joc
Ahir el vaig trobar
com veieu, còmicament inclinat
però no és tan dramàtic com sembla
Just a la zona
on va el meu matalàs, sota la tenda
era pla, i he dormit
bastant bé
Però bueno, acostat
Estic bé, estic acostat a la carretera
però estic força amagat
Bueno, tu
He pogut
Aquesta nit
a veure si torno a poder acampar
Molt bé
Següent destinació
seria la ciutat de Gilgit
que en principi arribarem demà
Així que avui dia de Caracorum
i Manta
No porto ni dos quilòmetres
i ja m'he parat d'esmorzar
perquè ara ve un tram
que no hi ha res durant bastanta estona
Ploreno una mica però sempre
acabo menjant el mateix
que és el pa aquest que porta
com greix, mantega
està bastant bo
ou i te
aquí no tenen
no tenen cafè
Bueno, ho heu vist, no?
No sé si ho heu vist però
al senyal posava
escola de nenes
crec que era
o de nens, no sé, bueno
que aquí les escoles públiques
separen nens i nenes
i escoles de nens i escoles de nenes
que no es podria fer per almenys
però que ara ja ho estan verdiant
amb les escoles
en els turistes
que quan van a l'escola
els estudiants
i els professors
s'educen
i els metges
que van a l'escola
han d'estar preparats
per a l'escola
i per a la ciutat
affected
o potser per a les escoles
però ara
no és unronics
per a la ciutat
s'han de drummer
per tu
per a la institució
per a l'estat
per a la ciutat
i per a la ciutat
Les 11.20
Atenció
perquè em trobo
al punt de col·lisió
de dues plaques
continentals. La placa
Índia col·lisiona
just aquí amb la placa
euroasiàtica.
Fa 50 milions d'anys
el subcontinent indi estava separat
del subcontinent
euroasiàtic
i va fer pum!
Va fer pum! Es va
ajuntar aquí i va crear
totes aquestes muntanyes, els Himalaias,
el Karakorum,
Tajikistan, l'Indocust,
totes aquestes muntanyes d'aquí es van crear
pam! Per aquesta col·lisió
que va ser progressiva i de fet encara
continua.
Cada any, o sí,
crec que era cada any,
són 5 centímetres el que es mou
aquesta placa i això fa que les muntanyes
creixin 7 mil·límetres.
Curiositat geològica
i a part d'això, aquest
lloc d'aquí seria un gran
lloc per acampar aquí a l'Arbeta.
Molt bé, tu.
Tinc les cames bastant
bastant
sobretot els quadriceps
amb agulletes d'ahir, no tant
de la pujada, sinó de la baixada, perquè va ser
baixada bastant ràpid, amb bastant
desnivell, és a dir,
bastant empinat,
1.400 metres de desnivell negatiu, pam!
I tinc els quadriceps ja estirant
que d'una estona
vaig parant i em vaig estirar una mica els quadriceps
però bueno,
el camí és molt plàstic. Jo no m'esperava
que la carretera del Karakorum
estigués tan bé, vull dir,
és ampla, està ben pavimentada
Sí que hi ha algunes llavissades
cop i volta, no es veu alguna pedra, però
està superbé, tu.
Les dotze i vint
pica el sol,
cau sol la justícia, eh?
A més,
fa tres hores que no descanso,
tres hores que camino seguit,
per tant, és un bon moment
per parar a dinar.
Això és el que m'encanta de Pakistan, que hi ha restaurants.
Sabeu com m'ha costat aquest matí
l'esmorzar aquest?
Un euro!
A veure què et donen avui per dinar, tu.
L'ideal sempre és una mica de verdura,
una mica d'hidrats, tipus arròs, pasta,
alguna cosa així, o patata,
i una mica de carn, una mica de botellina.
Això és l'ideal.
Després ja veurem, ja m'adapto.
A veure aquest lloc mateix,
si em donen de dinar.
A vegades em pregunten, què vols?
I jo, què tens? I em diuen, tinc això.
I què més?
Hello, how are you?
Good morning.
Can I have lunch?
Ok, I will sit there.
Thank you very much.
Doncs això, em diuen molts cops.
Què vols? I jo, bueno, què tens?
Diuen, tenim això.
I jo, bueno, tenim alguna cosa més?
I em diuen, no, només tenim això.
Això m'ha passat diverses vegades.
Llavors és com...
Perquè m'ofereixes la possibilitat, no?
Bueno, mira, aquest lloc està bé perquè està a l'ombra.
Aquí a l'exterior.
Doncs teníem ja llest el plof,
que és l'arròs aquest,
que ja l'havia provat l'altre dia a l'excursió,
però avui m'han portat una salsa
que no recordo el nom,
però és com de iogurt
i es veu que s'ha de menjar junt.
S'ha de posar aquí i menjar.
Anem a provar-ho, a veure què tal amb la salsa aquesta.
Thank you.
He demanat una ampolla i m'han portat una llauna, però bueno.
Bé, molt bé, tu, molt bé.
No posaré tota la...
Potser, eh?
Perquè m'agrada el contrast, però bé.
Molt bo.
Segueixo endavant,
ben alimentat i ben descansat.
He omplert aigua aquí,
això d'aquí,
a una aixeta que hi havia per ahir.
Me l'estic jugant molt perquè no estic filtrant l'aigua.
Jo pregunto, és bona?
I em diuen, sí, sí.
Evidentment,
ells tenen la flora intestinal diferent de la nostra
perquè ja estan acostumats a aquesta aigua.
Però, bueno, sí que és veritat que
aquí, doncs,
l'aigua ve de les muntanyes directament
i és raro que passi alguna cosa.
L'hauria de filtrar, ho sé.
L'hauria de filtrar, però de moment me la jugo.
Quan vagi cap a gotes més baixes,
ja serà una altra cosa.
I,rire,
què passa?
Dracues!
I això és el que ens va dir
florista.
Gràcies.
Bé, sempre us dic que tothom parla molt bé l'anglès aquí.
Com veieu, no tothom.
Bé, toca túnel, però és curtet aquest túnel.
De fet, és fals túnel.
És a dir, no és un túnel excavat a la roca, sinó un túnel que han posat aquí per protegir contra esgavissades i tal.
Mira, hi ha un petit voral.
Bé, són les 5 menys quart.
El sol se'n va a les... Ui, 5.36 oficialment.
A veure què trobo. Ja et dic, està xungo, eh? Aquesta vall.
Com veieu, la carretera va per aquí dalt.
I la zona plana, on potser podria posar la tenda, està aquí baix.
I clar, baixar per...
Per tornar a pujar es pot fer, però...
Home, fa una mica de pal.
Bé, aquí canvia una mica la història.
És una mica més pla. Allà és completament pla, però...
Està massa a la vista de la carretera.
I allà més endavant està com inclinat, però bueno, alguna cosa podríem trobar.
A veure, a veure què hi ha.
Espera, espera. I allà?
Tipo...
Veieu aquesta... com... mur de pedra?
Potser darrere?
Potser darrere estic tapat de la carretera.
Vaig a veure.
D'acord, ara no ve ningú.
Això d'aquí, aquest edifici d'aquí, no sé què pot ser.
No sé on és la casa, perquè...
No veig finestres, no veig cap rastre de la casa, però...
Ara m'ha vist una moto. No ha passat res, tu.
És que els faquistaners són molt curiosos.
Jo crec que si vaguessin a la meva tenda...
Segur que s'aproparien i m'oferirien alguna cosa.
M'oferien menjar, beure...
I cosa que està molt bé, però clar...
Jo no vull, perquè...
Si ve algú, jo no sé amb quines intencions ve.
Llavors ja...
De posar les primeres puntes, t'espantes, no?
A veure què tal aquí...
Bueno, lloc pla ja.
Ara és qüestió de... a veure si estic amagat prou de la carretera.
No veig els cotxes.
Normalment.
Si no els veig és que ells tampoc em veuen a mi.
Bueno...
No està mal...
No m'agrada el lloc 100%, perquè...
100% pla no és.
Potser una mica més enllà.
Bueno...
Busco un lloc, però crec que sí.
Crec que em quedo aquí.
Bueno, m'he trobat aquests dos joves.
Hello!
Hi!
Que els he dit, ostres, està bé si em quedo aquí, em diuen...
Sí, però els gossos vindran aquesta nit i t'atacaran.
Cosa que m'estranya perquè no veig absolutament cap gos.
Però me'ls crec.
Diuen...
Posa't per aquí, posa't per allà...
Estava tot obert...
I diuen...
Escoltes, vols quedar-te la masquita?
No parla amb més anglès.
I jo, bueno...
Si no és cap problema, sí.
Em puc quedar la masquita.
Està a un quilòmetre.
Sembla amb bona gent,
semblan de Fia.
Home, la masquita estaria millor que aquí, no?
Anem a veure, anem a veure.
5 i mitja, comença a anar el sol
Aquests nens m'estan liant perquè diuen
que clar, ara és l'hora de pregària
i podria entrar a la mesquita
a les 8 o a les 9, jo amb lo tranquil
que hagués acampat, però bueno
What is your name? My name is Mohamed Samir
And how old are you?
I'm 17 years old
17, eh? Very young
Ja s'ha fet el tio, eh?
Very good
What is the best thing about
this valley?
This valley is Nagar
o Gilgit?
I like Nagar
Li agrada molt
Jo els gossos no els veig enlloc, eh?
This place is
related from Gilgit, yeah
It's close, it's near
Yes, district is Gilgit
Tomorrow
Teòricament, allò d'allà
és una
mesquita i quan hagin deixat
de resar puc anar
Jo, la veritat, és que això em sona
molt estrany
Molt estrany
Són les 6, els nens
s'han anat i m'han dit, espera't aquí
això, aquestes dues o tres hores
i després ja baixes, i jo, sí
Sí, sí, sí, evidentment
però a l'igual
a l'igual
M'han fotut, m'han fotut aquests nens, a veure què faig
Perquè clar, ara les fosques
és, és un, és un rotllo, és un rotllo
A veure, o torno enrere
que he vist algun lloc interessant per acampar
Hello, hello
o vaig una mica més endavant
que segons el mapa hi ha un hotel
però no, no és molt de fi que aquest hotel existeix
Ostres tuers, maleïts nens aquests, tio
doncs al final el recurs fàcil
Guesthouse
però
amb un asterisc
i és que veig aquesta habitació i dic, bé
quin desastre
Al Google Maps només hi havia una review de fa un any
no sortia cap altre lloc més
i
i bueno, ja es veu que el lloc
bastant desastre, de fet hi ha alguna telaranya
M'obre el tio la porta al lavabo
i observeu
la quantitat de pols que hi ha
Vale, bé
Clean Iron aquí
aquí tindria per
per feina
Bueno, li dic
How much?
i em diu Free
Free
Pues Free, tu
Quin lloc més estrany, tu
La
la valla aquesta, aquests nens
Jo crec que els nens ho feien de bona fe, vale?
Simplement
tenien 17 anys
i no sabia, potser, molt bé el que es deia
no entenien que
que no puc estar dues hores sentat allà
saps?
Potser lo dels gossos ells no els han vist
Potser simplement els han dit
No, vigila que per la nit hi ha gossos, saps?
No ho sé
I aquí ara que em deixin estar gratis
Bueno
Segurament així no ho tenen habilitat com a guesthouse
però m'ho han deixat perquè dic, bueno, doncs mira
El noi que es queda aquí perquè si no estarà al castellà
El noi que es queda aquí perquè si no estarà al carrer
Però, clar, això pot ser un desastre, eh?
Si dormo aquí pot ser un desastre en quant a
infeccions, lo que sigui
Crec que el que faré serà muntar aquí el meu
el meu matalàs inflable
aquí al terra
i dormiré sobre i ja està
Bueno, ja ho veurem, eh? Però
crec que serà més higiènic
Vinga, deixeu-me
rentar-me els peus, lo que sigui
i fent resum
Bé
De moment
tot tranquil per aquí
No ha vingut ningú
De fet crec que puc tancar la porta, sí
No m'he atrevit a dutxar-me
però sí que m'he rentat els peus
hi havia una pastilla de sabó i tot
i una tovallola
que no m'he atrevit ni a tocar ni amb el braç
35 quilòmetres avui
una mica decepcionat
perquè avui he acampat, per tant
no he sortit a caminar a les 12
i només he pogut fer 30 això
35 quilòmetres
i per què he caminat fins a les 6?
M'he parat una estona llarga a dinar
i a esmorzar i tal
però clar, és que els dies cada cop
són més curts
i crec que
els dies de 40 quilòmetres
potser no tornen
Esporàdicament sí, però de manera recurrent
crec que
cada cop anirem més tirant cap als 30 que cap als 40
i a part d'això
dos tests
dos...
he parlat amb tres persones
els dos nens i un altre
m'he gastat avui
menys de 2.000 rupis
1.800
que vindrien a ser, posa-li
5 euros amb 50
dinar
esmorzar
i dos o tres supermercats
he comprat quatre coses
el país més barat de la història
fins ara el rècord se l'enduia
Uzbekistan
Uzbekistan, encara millor
Encara és d'hores, no necessipico
el que faré ara és gravar el podcast
amb el Sergi Marín
Normalment sempre el publiquem dimarts
o dimecres, com a molt dijous
però aquesta vegada sortirà més tard
Fem el que podem
i surt com surt
Quan veieu aquest vídeo ja estarà disponible
a Spotify, el teniu aquí, gratuïtament
i bueno, estem oberts a patrocinis
del podcast, si algú vol
fer un patrocini exclusivament del podcast
doncs estem obertíssims
perquè l'escolta molta gent
Aquesta vegada
ja sé del que parlaré, parlaré de
de l'excursió al Rakapochi
que clar, hi ha coses
que
no és tampoc molta cosa xitxa
però sí que hi ha coses que no puc dir al vídeo
perquè jo sabia que el Camil
que és el noi aquest
segurament miraria el vídeo
i tampoc volia explicar
molts detalls però els explicaré el podcast
el podcast sempre explico una mica de xitxa
D'acord, doncs jo demà
arribo a Gilgit on
m'agradaria comprar
i enviar les postals ja
a veure si hi ha sort, bona nit